business rules on bluemix gives you the
ability to configure orchestrate and run
your decisions in the cloud to get
started log into bluemix then go to the
catalog of services in the application
services section click on the business
rules icon then name your service and
click on the create button
the created service is displayed in the
connection
settings tab you can see how to start
the management console and how to reach
the service to rest or soap the decision
services tab shows the available
services you may like to invoke
the business rule editor plugin for
eclipse and lotus sample project in this
project you can see some rules used to
authorize a loan based on information on
the loan and the borrower flexible rules
define the maximum amount that can be
borrowed the acceptable credit score and
income
when you're happy with the business
rules you can deploy the project your
bluemix service after a few seconds your
project has been deployed in the cloud
going back to the server
and bluemix we can see the newly
registered service we can test it by
providing a test case and invoking the
loan service
we see that the credit score is too low
the loan is rejected
and we see that with the
higher credit score the loan would be
accepted
now the same web service
invoked and processed in the cloud from
any application running on bluemix or
on-premises thank you